التردد الالماني في ارسال دبابات ثقيله
لكيف يقلق اوكرانيا في لقاء مع امينو مجلس
الامن الاوكراني الى الحاجه الى تسريع
الامدادات
الظروف الحاليه ستجبرها على اتخاذ هذا
القرار لاننا لا نقاتله من اجل انفسنا فقط
يوم الجمعه لم تتوافق الدول الغربيه وعلى
راسها المانيا على ارسال دبابات ثقيله الى
كياف رغم مطالباتها المتكرره على خط
المواجهه بمحيطي محمود قد تحدث الدبابات
الحديثه المصفحه فارقا حقيقيا لكيا في
المعارك بالنسبه لنا فان الدبابات سترفع
من معنوياتنا لن نشعر بالخوف اذا استلمنا
الدبابات الحديثه مثل اليوفا او شلنجر من
المستحيل ايقافنا مع مثل هذه المركبات
يختلف الدور الذي تؤديه الدبابات في ساحه
المعركه يمكنها ان تسمح لكيف بمحاوله شنه
هجوم مشابه للمكاسب الميدانيه التي حققتها
في خاركيف لكن في انتظار ذلك المعارك
العنيفه مستمره شرق اوكرانيا في وقت تتدفق
فيه تعهدات بتقديم دبابات عربه واشنطن عن
ترددها بسبب صعوبه صيانتها والتدريب على
استخدامها في حين رفضت المانيا حتى الان
تقديم الدبابات